booster shot we got our booster shot and
we got our flu shot yesterday at the
same time so we both are having shivers
and major symptoms i don't say it's
major it's major i'm dying it's hard to
do anything except watch willow time so
jake has actually read the book as you
guys probably know and i
haven't we had completely too different
perspective over the plot the
characterization and things like that so
yeah we watched the show we watched the
first two episodes early we saw the
third one just right now i'm skeptical
about things there are things that i
don't like that they changed for sure
we're gonna first do non-spoilers and
then we'll do spoilers as always i don't
have any non-spoilers because i always
want okay but i want to hear as uh
someone who hasn't read the books what
is your impression it's just another
show you see on tv what do you think of
it i got the lord of the rings five a
little bit i really liked it um overall
hopefully when it gets to season eight
they wouldn't ruin it like game of
thrones did it feel like the pacing was
rushed or it was had a good tight pace
yeah do you like the tone
yep how would you describe the tone
well it is kind of sexy it is kind of
sexy it's sexy and bloody i thought it
was sexy depressing bloody what did you
think i'm i'm down this is fun i like
the darker tones they're going for i
mean i get they're trying to appeal to a
wider audience and i i really love the
eye of the world you know has a special
place in my heart even though i read it
not too long ago i don't i can't imagine
what it must be for like the long-term
wheel of time fans it's got to be really
difficult but there were things that i
think were improved the reordering of
certain events i will say tone wise a
little too
casual you know what i mean i think in
the third episode rand says like he says
[ __ ] he's like what the [ __ ] he doesn't
say what the [ __ ] but he's so surprised
you think that it should be more like
noble kind of language well not noble
but it's like there's not it's not like
casual like everyday talk i'll talk
about the third episode there are some
scenes in the third episode i don't like
thought the first and the second episode
i'm largely positive on it they had to
do certain changes and it worked mostly
it is by the third episode i start
noticing this casual tone and the way
people talk and it just started feeling
there was a scene in particular where it
just felt like is this wheel of time or
is this just some kind of like people
just hanging out in 2021 well i guess
like coming from a person who hasn't
read the books i actually like that
they're just just like hipsters just
chatting well i mean i don't know about
the dresses i didn't care either way i
felt like it was more relatable it made
it more so that you can identify
yourself with these characters i know
that this is really far moved into a
fantasy realm but at the same time it
felt like oh yeah i could see myself at
that bar something i love about the eye
of the world and something i think is so
underrated about it is this focus on the
grime and the details and the dirt but
they also change the characters in a way
where they're a little more world weary
when they go to shidar laga la shiddar
lagoth in the books there's this they
are all so innocent that's that's what
i'm kind of missing like right from the
get-go the characters are kind of jaded
whereas in the books they're like kids
well i think that's a great transition
to talk about spoilers actually you
should absolutely watch it because there
are some kick-ass moments i'm being a
little too negative right now because
they do so much right i highly recommend
there's a lot of potential there's just
there's a whole world of potential here
you know it's more of an ensemble right
now yeah main character and i really
felt like
i could really see how each person's
story was evolving or moving towards a
certain direction a lot of it
predictable so spoilers
can we talk about characterization first
yeah go for it whatever you want to say
i felt like a gwen
character was the most lacking
you know because from the beginning she
knew and i hate to make this comparison
but i kind of felt like it was paul from
june where it's like from the beginning
it's like she knew that she was destined
for like
something bigger and she was willing to
leave her relationship with ran for it
but ran for example he wanted to stay in
his village but she always saw herself
in a higher purpose granted we've only
seen three episodes but it didn't do as
much for character development you know
for example like matt you know he's such
a complex character like i know that you
told me in the book he's pretty you know
dumb
but
in the in the show i mean there were
times when i was like what the hell why
are you like especially when they were
at that place what is that place called
should i log off and then he was
stealing the knife they started off they
set it up really well with with him
stealing other stuff but yeah but i
wanted to scream in the book it's just
they're innocent it kind of works
because they're so naive they don't even
know they've never been to a city
they're just so
that's why i think like the fact that
they're actually more grown in the show
it makes it a problem if they were that
naive so you have to give it more
complexity and i think they did that for
everyone it's true there's a lot in the
eye of the world where you go well
they're young you know you forgive it
you're just they're young they're i'm
sure i mean i haven't read it but yes
but like in the in the show you know you
can't do that you can't do that because
it would be like a too much of
a grown-ass adult it's like yeah you're
using a writer's plot a little bit too
conveniently parent has a wife like come
on they're like well okay so i felt like
a gwaine's character was the most
lacking in development because she was
already who she was meant to be almost
in the very beginning right the person
who guided everyone through this can i
tell you how it is in the book with her
yes okay so they really front load like
her and rand's relationship because in
the book they're they're young but they
aren't at that level where they're like
dating each other it's just they've had
this idea since they were kids that they
would end up together and that they were
like promised for each other but they
aren't like
[ __ ] on like
in the inn you know washing dishes like
what the [ __ ] wayne values judy over
love and rand values love over duty and
thing that i love about his characters
thus far is that he goes from a person
who's like oh yeah i don't believe in
the dragon i don't believe in these
things and then he really you really see
him especially when he's separated from
aguain i know they're not as young as
you you know you say they are in the
books but he becomes a man and that's
very evident in episode three
when he's trying to persuade um matt
into going to the tower the other woman
i forgot her name who worshipped the
dark lord basically the dark one um
it looked like he could fall for someone
else brandon the book is just the most
awkward like i couldn't imagine rand
like having a conversation with a grown
female like that without just like
accidentally stabbing himself with his
sword and then just like crying one of
the funny things i love in the books is
that whenever
we're in parents pov when they're
separated he says ah man i wish rand
were here he always knows how to talk to
girls
and then in rand's pov he always says
and i wish parent were here he always
knows how to talk to girls
wow yeah that did not come across in the
screen at all he seemed very smooth it's
a sexy show there's lots of sex there
was a lot of sexual tension i felt like
and a lot of gore the surprising amount
of gore yeah oh yeah matt goes like oh
if naive were here with us she'd just be
arguing with moraine the whole time yeah
she's like yeah that's what hap that's
how that's how it happens yeah
um i thought her sexual chemistry do you
want to talk about the sexual chemistry
oh with lan
i thought like i was like and i didn't
know that they had something going on in
the book but like i thought they did a
great job who would you say is your most
favorite character thus far as far as
portrayal in the screen
matt
hm barney harris and sadly he's not
going to be in the next season okay can
we talk about him a little bit yeah i
thought it he had a brilliant complex
characterization they make it a lot more
interesting yes because he comes off as
a selfish person but in episode three
you really see that he's not because
he's doing all these things so that he
can get back to his sisters because his
mom can't protect his sisters this is an
example i think of the
show adding things that were good for
the character
but what they did with perrin after he
kills his wife it's like he just weighs
him down but he's just sort of dull i
felt like it was a little difficult it's
kind of boring
yeah you know the fridging trope of you
know to motivate him towards something i
don't know i feel like both
his character and also aguain's
character is a little too passive that's
so true and that's part of my problem
and i'm trying to figure out what it is
she's already made the decision
very like very beginning yeah but what's
interesting about her character in the
eye of the world is that she's divided
between a few things you know between
rand listening to naive and being a
wisdom and then the third thing pulling
her is moraine there's just a lot going
on with like wayne trying to figure out
her identity what she wants to do
there's just something off for me with
the characters and the the dynamic
between the characters rand and matt in
the books when they're off and on their
own they're screwed like they they're
just so hopeless like they're just so
dumb like they're so they're dumb kids
like they just don't know how the world
works they've been enough harm the whole
time you know they've lived on a farm
well that's exactly the opposite they're
very like very adult like okay you need
to
make sure
you have this job and do this thing you
know even matt even though he's like
pushing back and he's like portrayed as
somewhat more lazy yeah you know he's
still very like you know methodical and
he's he still understands real world
well do you have anything else to say
about the show i feel like we should
wrap up one thing that's interesting to
me is the premiere and talking to others
who have also read the book and are big
fans of the book itself they seem to not
like the show as much as new viewers
it seems like new viewers like the show
more than the fans of the books yeah
actually creators of the game of thrones
show were trying to lean away from it
being a fantasy show they're trying to
emphasize the non-fantasy elements
whereas i like that the wheel of time is
very much embracing the fantasy elements
the badass magic like
that's the funny part i felt like that's
how it started in uh episode one that it
was very fantasy based but as we're
getting further along it feels like it's
more rooted in reality all right thank
you for watching
um we
like the show we're very excited for the
new episodes yes i'm really bummed that
it's only one episode per week because i
would really love to binge this that's
all i got
cool
bye